jocko but
i'm so [__] tired
i should be finished with school in less
than a year and that will give me more
time to focus on training jiu jitsu and
hopefully competing i know this
craziness is short term and i have i
have to exercise discipline daily to
maintain this schedule can you just yell
something inspirational and motivational
at me so i have the sound bite to help
me get through the next 11 months
well first of all right on man um sounds
like you're doing your sounds like
you're crushing things and that's
outstanding
uh
can i go hard in the paint again
but here's the thing harden the paint
isn't me yelling
because i don't yell and believe it or
not no one really yells motivational
anything in the seal teams
and you know what else is interesting i
was thinking about this as i was
listening that question even in buds
even in basic seal training there's no
one that's yelling to motivate you they
might yell because you're slacking they
might yell because you're not putting
out and they're yelling at you at that
point because they want you to quit
they want you to quit why do they want
you to quit because no one wants anyone
in the teams that needs to be yelled at
to be motivated
i i don't want anyone that i have to
work with that they're gonna that
they're gonna the only way they're gonna
quote get motivated is if i yell at them
so we're not doing that you're tired
good
that means you're getting after it
that's what that means you got 11 more
months of this okay cool charlie plum
spent six years in her prisoner of war
camp
eating
eating a rice ball a day
being tortured being abused and he
complained less
in his book than you do in this one
question right here
alistar urquhart remember him the
forgotten highlander spent almost four
years as a pow of the japanese imperial
army he was tortured he was beaten he
was starved he had a nuclear bomb
dropped on him
he didn't complain
william reader we had him on this
podcast charlie plumb was on this
podcast william reader was on this
podcast bill reader colonel bill reader
pow in vietnam
in a two foot tall bamboo cage with his
legs shackled and he's trying to get
some sleep but he can't sleep because
the rats are gnawing at the wounds in
his legs
[Music]
who
who is there to motivate him
who is who is yelling at at captain plum
when he was being tortured in a prisoner
war camp to stay motivated
who who hyped up
alistair ercart to
to make it another day as a starving
slave in the jungle
who hyped him up
no one
so no i'm not going to yell something at
you i'm not going to hype you up i don't
need to you just need to get some
perspective
and wake up in the morning with that
perspective the perspective some
examples of which i just gave you that
life is short and every second is
precious so put your freaking head down
and keep getting after it